up on the mountain tonight for davey
martinez it is paulo espino he is 34
years old out of panama johnny is a
classic journeyman limited big league
innings he's making just his seventh
career major league start yeah pretty
amazing story when you think about how
long it's taken him and the longest
stint of his career up in the big
leagues well he's going to have a very
challenging effort here against the best
offense as far as discipline and
swinging at strikes
the left field for a base hit for murky
bets
he takes a wide turn and throttles back
to first for a lead off singles two outs
for ballinger
crazy pop up castro is there
round number three the lead up single by
mookie best goes no further kershaw 33
years old the three-time cy young award
winner former mvp coming off his
best start of the year
right away in play up the middle for a
base hit off of kershaw and the
nationals have the lead off and on here
in the bottom of the first inning
one hop
firing down to second back on to first
base for the double play
holds deluxe to pujols to god
smoke got to left field
out of the warning track
route number three
dodgers in the midst of their third
seven game winning streak or more
the one-two
swung on and miss strike three the
slider
first strike out of the game for kershaw
now victor robles no score bottom of the
third
homeless on a line out to left a leap
and pollock makes the catch and here is
paulo looking for his first hit of the
euro for six
one two swung on and missed strike three
on the slider second strikeout of the
game for kershaw
now is singled quickly by turner and
that sets the table two aboard
ballinger now the bases are loaded
nobody out top of the port
swinging away
robles
ranging back in front of the track
that's plenty deep enough muncie tagging
and coming home
going to third base everybody moves up
the station one out two in scoring
position for pujols
another one-two
fastball
soto deep and right makes the catch
turner's coming home
and
he slides across safe for the dodgers
get a couple of sacrifice flies to get
in front two-nothing
two outs two runs in they've got
bellinger at third base now here's gavin
lux
on one and one breaking ball
finds a base hit in the right center
field
that will score bellinger and lux
arrives at second base with a double a
much needed hit for gavin lux
knocking in his 33rd run of the season
bellinger comes in to score and the
dodgers take a three-nothing lead they
have two on and two out for yon gomes
who represents the tying run
lifted deep stroke way way back to left
field and gone two out home run off the
bat of yon gomes
i'd say that's a big two out hit
it's not a nationals game at home this
year without either sweltering heat or
rain and we've got the precipitation
coming down
the backhand harrison long throw and
zimmerman able to stretch
and get the out as the grounds crew will
get the tarp onto the playing field
we'll see how long this delay seems to
be well we are happy to say the baseball
will be played once again tonight about
an hour and 44 minute rain delay and
it's ryan harper up on the mound making
his eighth appearance for the nationals
rolled over towards the new man
cd's escobar now at the nationals
and all it took was an hour and 44
minutes to get those final two outs
clayton kershaw got to start tonight for
the dodgers he's done of course after
the rain delay bruised our granderol who
closed down last night's game and ending
in two-thirds the fire breather is up on
the hill
gets him on three pitches
john lester
and that dots the lower inside corner at
100.
it's leicester unless they're barking
about that goal dodgers in business now
in a tight sixth inning one out runners
down the corners and here's gavin lux
who ripped the run scoring double back
in the fourth inning his last timeout
swing it away
second punch out this inning that's two
on for pollock
some chopper
third base castro is
not in time
smith scores from third and the dodgers
get the lead back here in the sixth
inning
[Applause]
comes back up and he finds himself here
batting with the bases loaded in the
sixth inning down a run
and he gets para swinging right over the
top and he leaves them loaded
got their lead off man aboard here is
victor robles
robles pops a bunt and it's clanked by
turner
you get the out at second on escobar
who's coming in
maybe just
was looking at the runner at the same
time he thought he was going to squeeze
the ball easy out though
there goes robles and he's safe
once you can't believe it he's saying
take a look and we'll challenge this and
he's out
two outs nobody on dodgers by a run
zimmerman over three tonight
lined and gobbled up by lux what a play
he lassoes that and it is out number
three zimmerman hit it about as hard as
he possibly could
lux one step to his left snared it threw
him out and the inning is over
one gone top of the ninth and speed at
second base
three and two to chris taylor there's
the pitch
he lines up base hit into left field lux
rounding third
he's on his way home throw to the plate
not in time taylor delivers a big
insurance run for the dodgers who now
lead it five to three dodgers lead it by
two and they hand the keys over to
kenley janssen who has been fantastic
this year
first pitch swinging laced into left
field
castro on base for the third time
tonight it brings the tide run to the
plate and yangon
to aboard
para bats here representing the winning
run
he got him
city's escobar making his nationals
debut tonight
and he puts them away with the heat on
three pitches
and the nationals
who began this in with a single and a
walk are now down to their final out
bell the last hope for the nats tonight
two outs and two on down by two jansen
to bell
and he pokes him right into the glove of
gavin lux dodgers beat the nationals by
a score of five to three